foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
eight eight three one
one eight eight one
go away
eight three three one
okay eight
oh you've got to be kidding me
right away Property Management
[ __ ] kidding me
hi this is Tess Marshall I'm uh in town
I'm at the house on Barbary and I'm on
the porch and it's pouring the brain and
there is no key in the lock box so
please could you just call me back on
this number
thank you
God damn it
[Music]
[Music]
um
I'm sorry who are you
what who are you
this is 476 Barbary right
I don't know yeah yeah I think so you
don't know
no
I don't live here I'm renting this place
it's the middle of the night I don't
have it in the top of my head the
address no I'm running this place what
I'm running this place I I booked it on
Airbnb like a month ago I booked a home
away you're [ __ ] kidding wait wait
are you sure you have the right place
yeah I
yeah my email says 476 Barbary that's
here right and my code works for the
lock box
I'm supposed to be in here
did you try and call someone yeah no one
answered
and you sure you have the right date
look
yeah I mean it looks right
[ __ ] that's unbelievable
what am I supposed to do
I don't know I don't know
why don't you why don't you come inside
and we'll call these idiots
[Music]
uh would you mind if I uh yeah
I I need to use a bathroom
yeah yeah yeah of course it's uh just
down the hall to your left
okay I'll be right back
[Music]
would you mind pulling up your
reservation confirmation just so I can
see it
in case I'm some kind of weirdos broken
in here to sleep
yeah no it's fine let me just find my
phone
foreign